To Brazil, where more than 600,000
people have now died from COVID-19.
Activists in Rio de Janeiro displayed 600
white handkerchiefs in tribute to the victims.
The memorial ceremony on Copacabana beach
was organized by the NGO Rio de Paz.
Many in Brazil blame President Jair Bolsonaro
for the deaths. Bolsonaro has consistently
downplayed the danger caused
by the virus and anger at his
handling of the pandemic is growing.
In Brazil, 600,000 people have now died
from COVID-19 infections, the second highest
death rate in the world after the US. Brazil's
President Jair Bolsonaro has repeatedly
downplayed the threat posed by the virus,
and opposed measures like mask wearing, limiting
activity or encouraging vaccination. Brazil's
senate is investigating Bolsonaro for politicizing
the pandemic and failing to secure oxygen,
and vaccines for the country. People
angry with the government's management,
have taken to the streets to call for change.
Frustration – taken to the streets of Brazilian
cities. Directed mainly at the country's
corona-skeptic president, Jair Bolsonaro.
No country has been able to escape COVID
-19, but many here are angry that Brazil has
lost so many lives. With 600,000, it's
the 2nd highest death rate worldwide.
Per capital Brazil is among the top ten countries
suffering the greatest losses, leading the
demonstrators here to call for impeachment.
"This is a pandemic-denialist government,
spreading a policy of death, whose economic
agenda has driven people to starvation.
We are in a desperate situation here,
and the President doesn't seem to care."
Even as Brazil dominated global headlines with
spikes in infections and images of
mass graves shared around the world, Bolsonaro
didn't change his tune, calling the deadly virus
"just a little flu" and minimizing the
strain and losses people were suffering from.
He has also repeatedly spoken out against mask
wearing and vaccines, while promoting unproven
medicines for use by doctors -- including
recently in a speech at the United Nations.
"We respect the patient and doctor relationship,
with the decision on the medication to be
used and the potential for off-label use."
Within the government, there are also concerns.
For months, Brazil's senate has been investigating
Bolsonaro's pandemic management, including the
use of taxpayer money to purchase experimental
medicines. Just last week, whistleblowers
detailed information about a hospital chain
pushing the use of such off-label meds
on the elderly -- without their consent.
"So the doctors explained to me they gave the
COVID kit of meds to the patients and told them:
'I have to give this to you, because if I don't,
they can fire me. But I can tell you that if you
take anything from here, take only the proteins
and the vitamins, because the other medicines,
besides having no efficacy, can be very
dangerous, specifically for the elderly.'"
Bolsonaro's approval rating has slipped to just
22-percent. But not everyone has criticism for
the president. On September 7, large crowds came
out to show support for Bolsonaro on National Day.
But as the pandemic continues to take lives,
several local governments are moving forward
with their push to vaccinate, even extending
shots now to young people. More than 200
municipalities are also introducing a vaccine
passport - which Bolsonaro strongly opposes.